this show is brought to you by me undies
go to me on these calm / Joey to get
twenty percent off of your first order
you can get a subscription or a single
pair you go to me I'm nice calm / Joey
to get twenty percent off of your first
order and shipping is always free in the
US and Canada and you can save up to
eight dollars a pair what the me on just
a subscription plan shows also brought
to you by headspace go to headspace calm
right now and download their free
headspace after giving every listener of
the church was having now a free trial
of their head space app and begin their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation that's headspace calm / Joey
to download the free headspace app shows
also brought to you by ona calm go to on
it calm and use covert church to save
ten percent on all of their great
optimization products like alpha brain
shroom tech immune and shroom texsport
kick that mother
broccoli Wednesday May eighteenth you
bad [ __ ] smoking token light
yourself on fire I don't give a [ __ ]
it's Wednesday [ __ ] the day the devil
was buried at sea what respected [ __ ]
um where's Hillary yet yeah until I call
Oh what Lisa I yet Joey the kettlebell
alvarado I love that [ __ ] jam first
time i heard that jammed almost jumped
out a window it's an awesome song it was
in boulder colorado and I heard it in
the copland and koplo under the bridge
that's the music that's just alone right
yeah that's the music the black guys
playing with the machine go back and
wonder boy jumps off the [ __ ]
building and you hear that jam in the
car kit don't gun and the guys driving
by you like Jesus [ __ ] when did you
start getting into rap or hip-hop I
guess not out public enemy you know
listen you you got into rap if you liked
hip-hop whatever the [ __ ] I uh I said
the hip hop yeah yeah old school that's
all stuff right there and then you know
it evolved over the years and then I
don't know I really like Public Enemy
yeah i was back like way back then i
would Kurtis Blow and all those yeah
yeah well I like basketball all right
guys about worthless so that that's what
was in it was like Kurtis Blow the fat
boys run DMC so Afrika Bambaataa I
wanted for child molestation now and
[ __ ] what yeah sure I read an article
yeah like all the black men should read
this and african boom bada molested a
bunch of [ __ ] oh yeah they had like
kids like a bodyguard it's a bit like
everywhere they would just bring like
teams of them in like you have some
travel allegedly I don't know everything
but according to the article yeah
wow that is [ __ ] it's like a grown
[ __ ] man you know and i'll tell you
when i was a kid i suspected somebody on
my in high school but I never heard some
a friend of mine told me if he saw
somebody sucking his dick one time he
took me the basketball there wasn't [ __ ]
i only got molested one time like when i
tried to molest me one time in the
wintertime I serious i went down to play
basketball you know i was a
basketball-playing it snowed and when it
snowed in the East [ __ ] close it
snowed for two days and lock the city up
there was so the buses instead of
running every 15 minutes there were like
every two hours so i think i got a ride
down there but on the way back
everything freezes up it gets nighttime
it's dark and I'm not hitchhiking I'm
just waiting for the bus and some dude
pulls over and he [ __ ] and he went to
hit the ball and when he went to touch
egos you like basketball only what they
hit the boy he slipped and grabbed my
[ __ ] and at the next [ __ ] like God
was in the car cuz the door just opened
up and I ran out of the car and I ran
across the street to shoot some park I
tell you this last week no no no you
want I think I've heard the story the
basketball before but I ran across the
street to shits in park shits in park is
an old [ __ ] german place sits in car
that i grew up with it's a banquet hall
and then if they have a soccer field and
when i was a kid we play baseball back
there but every once in a while the chef
they called him to cook or something the
shaft or whatever he come back there
with a hacker and a dog and SiC the dog
on young we'd be motorcycles back there
but they also had a soccer stadium and
they had what's that metal that you sell
sheet metal as a roof so people can sell
into the Sheep Meadow when we find out
we got to build a sheep dog if you go to
that stadium right now for reigns those
[ __ ] a [ __ ] happy took every
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that one piece
at a time we go up there were 13 we knew
nothing about nothing but we knew if we
got a piece of sheet metal we can chop
it four ways it's 25 bucks when you're
[ __ ] 13 that's a little bag of reefer
a pack of beer a couple hits of acid
pretty smart yeah maybe an album and
[ __ ] so we went back there it was a
german place i ran in there just note so
i hid behind
a snow pile and I took like a bottle and
weight of him to drive him but he never
came in he had a bottle just waiting to
crack just ready to throw it at them
with the window open and run get him
good and ready [ __ ] runner maybe call
the cops or whatever see he didn't know
the back of that a place like I knew I
grown up in those [ __ ] woods I caught
ringworm every summer I knew those woods
like the back of my [ __ ] hand I
really did man so if you chased me into
those woods you were dead man you were
not gonna find me because I knew those
woods yeah man it's like Fort Jackson
South Carolina I grew up on Fort Jackson
South Carolina for a long time and man
the woods over there that was like our
home that you homes are stopping
wretches and I know the reports in there
we knew I all know the true yeah where
the creek was we're to cross a creek
everything about that's cool somebody
chases you they're [ __ ] done that's a
poisonous leave him into traps and stuff
what stuff now I mean we just about that
picture today on Twitter stuff changes
all the time what do you think you could
still go in those woods like we got that
picture of hash ways that's now
something yes it's a Cuban place I knew
that I didn't go into nobody has gone
into that Cuban restaurant because it
was like laughs like a 40 year
restaurant in my hometown like a deli
and it was a liquor store deli and they
opened up a Cuban place in there and
nobody's got like everybody I talked
about a cashier is my fellow my know it
have you been to Luna i drive by and I
never seen anybody in there people won't
go in there because it meant so much to
us it's like our NAL's and happy days
hmm where'd you grow up you grew up
everywhere right but although it may
have a good memory Joey no I don't yeah
[ __ ] yeah I did i was born in LA my mom
remarried my stepfather was in the
military we moved to Germany South
Carolina Belgium back to Jeremy back to
South Carolina then I'm an Ellie now I
remember you telling me stories as a kid
in Belgium that's right how do we were
you involved in Belgium and I even know
what Belgium was when my dad was like
we're getting stationed in belk outside
el djem what would you they speak they
speak two different languages speak
French and they speak Flemish Flemish
Flemish yeah in the different regions
you know I think Flemish is a
combination of like
in some are they gonna how long did you
live there for four years man for yer so
I movie I wish you smoked refill that is
the first place of smoking they have
hash and every talks kidda me mad and
you know like in Europe that's all all
this cash that's all they smoke man so I
yeah that was the first first thing I
smoke was hash because I mean Amsterdam
was only two hours away so like when I
moved to Belgium I was just like what do
people what do we do here and people
were like oh we hang out in bars like
what are you talking about well there's
no drinking age it's just like that's
the culture you know what I mean how old
were you at that point 14 years old man
so like it's not even lying magic ask
any of my my friends on facebook from
shape Belgium we were hanging out in
bars on the weekend man you know the
bars we would take the train to ours way
to go to Amsterdam hang on amsterdam for
the week and stay at a little hostile
sometimes even just like stay up all
night or and sleep in a little corner in
the street or something you know but
yeah man that's all they smoked over
there was hash and then they had these
little bars outside of the base that we
used to hang out in and you know what's
crazy is like air just about everybody
smoked everybody drank and everything
but everybody and in my high school
graduated there was like no teenage
pregnancies there were no fights ever
not crazy you think cuz little reefer I
don't know man I've never I never smoked
a smoke to join or anything they want to
punch somebody in the face Oh me neither
it's the worst when you get high and
somebody ruins your [ __ ] high with
dumb [ __ ] I was just sitting here
minding my own [ __ ] business what was
it like when like when you because you
said he came back and forth to the US a
couple times haha after being a
fourteen-year-old in a bar and doing
that and then coming back in 14 year
olds are going on play dates in the
backs of vans like it was a weird his
madness it's different it was culture
shock because I lived in outlet from 14
years old do like 90 years old in
Germany and Belgium so everything is
Matt it's like culture shock so for
eight years I was over there and then I
went right back to South Carolina which
is like the Bible Belt you know so it
was just different man you know it's
different and I had just barely turned
and I was just I was 20 years old when I
moved back to south
honor so then um I couldn't even drink
at that time I now remember i remember
my my brother-in-law took me to a strip
club whenever when I was when I turned
21 yeah so it's different managing her
like I've been I've walked around
Amsterdam some from the time I was 14
the strip club isn't really that I said
yeah it's really weird when you change
cultures like I always tell lately we
grew up in a big place like he grew up
in Boston well I grew up in Jersey you
know I was in that [ __ ] big city
every goddamn day so it's really weird
when I left New York I stopped doing a
lot of this [ __ ] I stopped doing because
I wouldn't get the satisfaction Boulder
and Colorado had other things to offer
me other than New York so you have to
win what in Rome mean I'm saying yeah
you know when I went to boulder at first
and I went to Aspen or something how am
I gonna ski and I'm like what what am I
an [ __ ] yeah what am I [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm back here with this mandala
you know like when I what does iris over
that time I got in trouble as a kid when
I was 19 I didn't go on the lam for a
few months and i went to Sarasota I was
in shock like the kid I was staying with
was my age and we had gonna my school
together now he's living in Sarasota and
he had gone on high school in Sarasota
for like three years and I went to visit
him and it was like this is what you
[ __ ] do you forget we go to the beach
and sing songs are you [ __ ] crazy you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh you know it was so
weird the culture shock like when i went
from even New York City to snowmass
village and I would go to those bars at
night and I go this is I'm at work this
is not gonna work I know you don't
remember but did your mom ever talk
about going from Cuba to New York City
cuz I can't imagine you were what 633
from Havana to [ __ ] Manhattan Wow
could you imagine like I wish you had a
journal or something I don't remember
remember nothing like nothing like this
night remember looking at a beach that's
it that's all I remember about Cuba
beach when I was a kid I had more
memories like I would tell my mom I
remember my dad and Cuba driving but now
that shit's gone you uh definitely go to
Cuba supposed to be um one of the top
places to go for single men yeah cuz you
could [ __ ] hookers with two hours that
why yeah how does just easy to find a
girlfriend over there is no I know
there's no girlfriends over there the
girlfriend you stay over there unless
you want to bring back some chick the
lamar odom ii eight years ago on the
ranch and as they ship the back to Cuba
Catriona she yeah man you know I think I
had the most culture shock cuz whenever
I moved from South Carolina to LA man I
was just sounds like a while people
could sense that I was so wet behind the
ears man but when I met you I banged you
for Easter way right off the [ __ ]
back no questions really right off the
bat and then I'm like a lily I and the
guy said you had a school uh somewheres
on my guy you know the guy that's hurt
right now look at the big deal Anthony
any I mean yeah yeah he said running
with you before yeah and that uh so I
see him he's a Mexican looking dude
you're a Mexican looking dude i put
together you think you did you take a
look mexican really yes I don't you ever
get that man I never get built and
you've always people ask me you know i'm
one of a [ __ ] ash I'm like a guy room
like a chameleon I've I've had people
think I was armed am sure I think I mean
when I tell people I'm I'm like I'm half
mexican half spanish so they're like
really I wouldn't have guessed that I've
had a guy tell me I was thought I was
Filipino because my dad my dad actually
looks like he's Philippine he could pass
for a filipina he's like shorter and
darker than me but yeah I had the most
culture shock whenever I move from South
Carolina to to LA in which way I'm sorry
man I just you know I've never been
around gangs I never been around crime
or anything men
and like when I moved into my first
little paddle we heard my pad was robbed
and I just remember like coming home and
my had this new DVD player and and every
time I would drive home and there'd be
like these two little cholos just like
sitting there like looking at me like
this that is like what are these fools
doing they're casing out my patna
they're casing out my bad so when I came
home one day man must all my stuff was
gone well it's scary but when you're
made oh man they're the smart dude
they're smart they're smart but then
like I got lucky when I moved to you're
just good into west LA like no cuz I
look for apartment and be like Baldwin
Hills or like I know comptons not good
there's some areas that aren't good and
there's no like this there was a girl a
guy apparently when Paula still lived in
my girlfriend live in Inglewood huh she
was like guys white white like me and
just moved in there to go to college in
the wood yeah but they're all even think
I've ever been yeah maybe I have did you
like this off cuz I I haven't got to
spend like a week or so in the South
Island I drove through it I loved
everyone was so nice and laid back it
seemed great because you're white that's
also probably true but that's probably
like I lived there as a kid too like we
forgot about like I was born here we
moved to Germany we moved to South
Carolina so we live in South Carolina
first like seven years so that's
whenever I was like that's when I
started getting like I really felt like
a lot of racial tension over there
people would always ask me like what are
you you know they didn't know because it
was because it was either white or black
over there you know it was you know I
have my you know it was a trip you know
I got bullied a lot too and that's what
led to martial arts and everything too
so but I mean it's pretty boring man you
know I mean it's just a different it's
just a different on whole different
lifestyle out there man I like la you
know as soon as I came out to LA I was
like this is where I was supposed to be
the whole time because I mean this is
where my roots are anyway you know
despite the Robin yeah yeah I was born
here you know all my family's from here
my mother and my father were from here
you know my sisters were born out here
as well you know when did you get into
martial arts holy man like nine like
nine ten yeah in South Carolina because
and the whole reason was was I was
getting
all time in the brothers used to kick my
ass dude I don't know why I was like the
little Puerto Rican look I think it was
because the sisters like me you know
they like I was like the little cute
Puerto Rican boy you know I was a little
curly I I staff here by the way
everybody goes like when they see me
with hair they're like oh professor you
had hair before I got here I had a lot a
lot of curly hair man so the black girls
used to dig me man and I don't know if I
don't know why but man has to get my ass
kicked I just come on crying all the
time and my parents you know my my dad
my stepfather he was like from the
avenues and he wasn't like the fighter
he was the fighter guy you know he boxed
a little bit so he'd knock fools out so
he was like he knew how to fight you
know and he was abused that he was a
tough guy and my mom too she was crazy
you know she was from Dogtown and they's
to get really pissed off man there's to
be like why don't you [ __ ] fight back
you know you gotta fight back nobody
moves good I'd be crying and [ __ ] you
know and and then they know like I think
I was scared because they were black to
you know like you know intimidating out
there was very intimidating for me man
they're like you know what everybody
bleeds red my mom would say you know and
then finally I came home one day man
crying again and they're like that's it
man you know we got you got a stick up
for here so we got to do something so
they took me at that time Tae Kwon Do
was blowing up tae kwon was just it was
like on the verge of blowing up so they
took me to on moreland taekwondo academy
and master moreland uses black guy that
lived in Korea he was stationed in Korea
in the army and he spoke fluent Korean
man and he was it was like a master of
Taekwondo man he took it he used to come
pick us up in his little Taekwondo van
I'm base and pick air all the kids up in
the neighborhood he would take us over
there traina so you kick our ass and
then we'd all be crying in the van on
the way home like we're all like such
little wusses met it was funny really
mm-hmm because he would spar with this
man I know when I look backward just
we're just [ __ ] basically man you're
just winery weird look little babies man
you know he we thought it would he was
beating though somebody really wasn't
man we were just like scared you know
but uh man he talking me up man it took
me a couple years because even after
taking Taekwondo for a couple years I
still hadn't really grown up and got
that confidence yet you know so on
I was like a late bloomer man but yeah I
did Taekwondo with master Moreland for
for like the whole time I was in South
Carolina and hapkido and then um then we
moved to Belgium did some Taekwondo over
there play a little football played a
little baseball you know party a little
bit move to Germany and then I would
train at like little local local places
you know it